[Musique]
des quatre coins du monde il s'arrête
pour admirer
l'instrument des quatre coins de la
région ils viendront l'applaudir ce
soir l'orue de la collégiale saintro
fabriqué par vercraft un factcteur
Allemand va fêter ses 10 ans considéré
comme l'un des plus beaux du monde en
raison de sa sonorité exceptionnelle il
est la fierté de
Montelimar Henri François velut a débuté
lor à 13 ans il en a aujourd'hui 35
premier prix de virtuosité titulaire de
l'or d'une paroisse de Genève il est la
fierté de son professeur qu'il a connu
tout
petit j'ai commencé à l'âge de 4 ans en
du piano et puis aussi longtemps je se
me souvenir j'ai désirit faire de
l'ordre je cherchais à imiter au pianau
comme j'ai trouvis en appuyant sur sur
la par exemple le son son de
l'org l'ampleur du son de l'org et dès
que mes parents sont venus s'établir à à
montellimar l'occasion s'est trouvé
réalisé de manière idéale avec Pier
Simonet qui m'a donné mes premiers
courours
d' si les ores sont dans les églises ce
n'est pas une raison pour ne jouer que
du bac c'est le Paris d'Henri François
velut qui fera vibrer les Boutes de
Sainte Croix ce soir au son de pièces
contemporaines étonnantes et parfois
même dansant
I